and then when they threw away the card
keys i tried to get back out of the car
to go to the doctor's office to call the
sheriffs
and ultimately the sheriffs came and
when the sheriffs came they did this
report and they called the paramedics
because of the blood on her arm
right and the sheriffs came and the and
the conclusion of their report
was that it was incidental contact that
happened when i was trying to leave that
they had followed me there
and that i was trying to get away you
know it was no incident
and the paramedics report was she had a
graze on her arm
and she refused further treatment and
put the pain
at a two on a scale of one to ten
that is the basis now for scientology
claiming
that i have beaten up my ex-wife right
that is seeing a video of that yeah i
caused her
permanent physical damage now the story
is
the bones they my daughter could hear
the bones breaking in her shoulder
that she has had to have operations that
she has had
permanent neurological damage that
she'll never recover from
she can't sleep because she's in such
pain
and this is now the campaign
of justice for mum
which is the website that ostensibly
is the website of my daughter and this
is put up by the office of special
affairs
and is tried to tack on to the metoo
movement
and my daughter got sent out and you
know
got a picture taken with gretchen
carlson and
with jackie lacy the district attorney
in los
angeles and the mayor of l.a in all
these women's
metoo movement events yeah with the
justice for mum and
that's still going on that's still
that website still exists she still does
posts on it and in their video they even
had like a
legitimate orthopedic surgeon in
california i don't know that he was a
legitimate orthopedic surgeon but he
googled him he had a website i don't
know if he's legit now he might be a
scientologist
right yeah i wouldn't doubt it is uh
those reports the like the paramedics
report in the police report from that
incident is that available
publicly yeah i've got it on my blog
it's on various other blogs it's
been put like a lot of people have taken
this up and gone
wait a minute what's going on there deep
enough you can find out
yeah yeah you don't have to look very
far you can just look at my what
on my blog i think i have a post on
there say that's called
mike rinder ladykiller or something
right and
where i just went through and laid all
this out
and in fact in one of the upcoming
episodes of the
of the um new podcast with leah
we talked about this it hasn't had yet
but okay
and i'll have all the documents because
i i created a little website to go with
the podcast
that just has the documents that we talk
about on the podcast
okay that website while you're talking
that website got hacked before it was
even live
holy [ __ ] these people are relentless
totally totally now did you ever worry
like fear for your own physical safety
or is it just kind of like
cyber stalking people you know following
you around
i mean i know it can get weird but has
it ever come to like any sort of
physical threat
well the physical the only physical
thing was this
incident in the doctor's parking lot
okay that was
that was physical but no
this is mind games okay you know it's
the prison of belief
and it's the mind [ __ ] of yeah
i'm going to make you believe
that bad things are gonna happen to you
and unless you stop and
i'm gonna make it uncomfortable and
unpleasant and make you worry about your
family and etc etc but
i have never thought that that
any physical damage would happen
i mean a few times some of the pis have
gotten sort of out of control
one of them ran into the back of me one
time
they've you know done crazy
like driving down gulf to bay and
literally no u.s 19
and literally trying to keep up with me
driving through over the center median
on us 19 in order to
not get left behind at a light and
you know that sort of stuff but as for
you know
sending around the thugs with baseball
bats no
i don't yeah i'm never worried about
that going back i meant to ask you this
earlier
how could you possibly get into a
scenario
where you're somewhere with david
miscavige
who is like the supreme leader of
scientology
and he is beating you up
how does that situation come about and
what is the point of it
um well how does that situation come
about it just happens that's sort of on
a routine daily basis of anybody that's
working around or with him
like what is he does he punch you in the
face that he's like sometimes what does
he slap
kick comes up behind you
and grabs you around the neck in a
headlock or wrestles you to the ground
just random he's like an angry little
man
right and you know he he grew up as a
wrestler
that was what he did and he sort of
uh takes out his
aggression and frustrations physically
i mean he's also very abusive verbally
too
i mean he's like incredibly
verbally abusive as well but
this happens routinely anybody that
worked with him and you know i don't
know that he hasn't
stopped doing the physical stuff when
it's now that it's become
so exposed uh
at least limited the the
scope of it to only the very very
inner circle but for a while
it was you know very routine
and in
you get into a frame of mind that is
so insane that you believe
that and this is a sort of a fundamental
belief of scientology
that whatever happens to you is
your own fault that you have
done something that has caused that to
happen to you
so when david miscavige wails on you
your inclination is to go what have i
done that has
caused the leader of scientology to be
so upset
that he has lost his [ __ ] mind
yeah and that is hammered in
and hammered in and hammered in and you
start to wonder whether
it's you that is the problem and
honestly the people that remain there
who used to be the senior echelon of
scientology
those people all believe that it's them
that they're nuts that they're evil and
that
they have failed to
adequately support david miscavige in
his
campaign to save the world i mean
i know how nuts this sounds danny and i
know
that a lot of people go how could you
not
see this how could you and there is a
lot of reasons for it
and you know
i saw it maybe two years before i
ultimately left
but the consequences of leaving are so
terrible in your mind that
you don't want to take that step i did i
knew that i would lose
the woman i'd been married to for more
than 30 years i would lose my kids i
would lose my
mother and brother and sister i believed
at the time that i would lose my
spiritual eternity
and that i would walk out into the world
you know 50 years old with no money
no college degree no
i mean a resume of i was the
spokesperson for scientology
isn't much of a resume and i had nowhere
to go
so that is what kept me
there for the last number of years
until ultimately i was in
england dealing with the bbc and
miscavitch started sending things saying
you're never coming back to the united
states
you're a piece of [ __ ] you never blah
blah blah blah and i went personally
sent you these things
yeah what were they like emails letters
just
yeah letters like a letter and uh
i then went well okay
i don't have much left to lose
and eventually i sort of reached the
point of
well nothing can be worse than this
and i literally walked out of the
scientology building in in london
into the street with a briefcase
two blackberry phones my passport and a
hundred pounds
that's it i didn't have any clothes i
didn't have
anything i didn't have anywhere to go i
got on the tube
and i went to leicester square and i sat
and then i
wandered around in london for a couple
of days and then i eventually called
tom de vocht who was one of the other
people that is
in the truth rundown series
and who i had known since he was a child
and he had left the sea org previous to
me
and he was in orlando and i got a plane
and flew to orlando and stayed with him
for a while
and then i went from there very shortly
thereafter
and stayed with ronnie and bitty
miscavige
david miscavige's older brother who had
also left the sea org
yes what was that what was it like
dealing hanging out with them and being
around them well they were very very old
friends i mean they were my closest
friends
in the sea org i had known bitty since i
had arrived
her name is elizabeth since i had
arrived on the apollo and as i said
ron junior from when he had first
arrived in the sea org
and we had been very close our kids had
grown up together
jenna muscavich who ultimately wrote a
book after she left about her
uncle was really raised with my son
benjamin together
they were like brother and sister and uh
it was it was very very helpful to me
because ronnie and bitty had left a
couple of years
before me and it takes a while to
unravel your thoughts and how you see
things and what you think about things
and figure out whether
you're looking at something because
that's what scientology taught you
or you're looking at something because
that's what it really is
and it's it's a real a real process
to come out of that cocoon
of that prison of belief and it was very
helpful
having them being such close
dear friends who had already
gone a long way down that path
and biddy was the one that said to me
when i first arrived there you've gotta
you've got to write
immediately and demand that kathy my
ex-wife
come and see us because she was
kathy's best friend and so
i wrote to the office of special affairs
i knew exactly who to write to and i
wrote to them i said
i want to see kathy
and she answered back i got a
handwritten note back from her saying
uh dear mike [ __ ] you i failed the
divorce papers
[Music]
[Laughter]
wow